I don't think Muslim needed to actually
like kind of show up for that the points
here like a lot of them are sitting on
like the really good points
one thing I love about RMD - coming from
the UK I love that he always wears the
bright beanie like the bright like
highlighter green one yesterday well so
you know for like for me I'm not like a
hat person at all yeah but I love beings
actually I'm like a big fan like when
it's cold outside you know it hits the
frigid temperature of like 60 I'm like
oh man it's so cold out here cold I'm
like California hit 60 I'm I guess as a
real winter I gotta throw on the beanie
Oh what did he give up you got candy
what is that is this the powerup candy
he was eating earlier so so that looks
like he's chewing on right now he he
when he won his game earlier he popped
in that candy and he was chewing on it
and then he ended up winning so maybe is
he sharing this tag right now against it
oh yeah that's very sweet of you know
the he just leaned over like hey let me
try one of those look that's that's the
generosity of the Japanese oh yeah if I
just saw this guy on the streets I
wouldn't against it right like I'm like
wow who's this guy with his Joe Dirt
moment situation going on here but any
idea who I really not actually it would
be sick if that was like you took that
into the barber I was like can you can
you give me with this guy he's like
David Spade this is my hero right now a
big fan locked and loaded
I wonder this might be a bunch I didn't
see who they pick yeah it's like yeah I
think the team on the left is actually
team AAA like if you mash AAA at the
menu on one piece odd and that's the
team you get and I think the same for
the other team is the ghost of tachikoma
past that's true actually yeah all three
are ghosts of tachikoma past me neither
three of them exist anymore on his team
all right be that a good run you know
maybe hope I just always hope that he'll
become the hipster player that he once
was again
I know it's harder it's a lot harder
it's weird because like his new team is
like it looks like he's trying to win
but like maybe he hasn't committed all
the way arrives you get a combo for a
second things like he's sick my boys
he's like when I played this character
played this team let me show you by my
B&B with my team I was always so
exciting - yeah he would always do that
this is you know I would always have the
the stance ready the head so oh man all
right looks like we're like locked and
loaded here lose a side match obviously
this goes home with seven place and
winner will move on to play against
topology man which will be the next set
of matches we have will be subversive
an apology man vs. the winner of this
those are all the losers scores matches
that's are gonna be coming off on the
bracket we showed the bracket if you
missed it smashed our GG you might be
able to exclamation point bracket in the
chat actually maybe well they didn't
pick the Cell Games arena we would have
gotten the intro the special intro yeah
West City it is oh that's my favorite
part select the step select the mute and
then you're already in there it's too
late you just mash through it that's
what they're doing
alright locked and loaded teams are sat
here warming up that square button yeah
you have to especially I mean you got a
bar talk and you have a team going on
and you have a GT Goku all three
characters fantastic O'Connell's yeah
and I think this is a really good choice
of a team though for Tachikawa he's
definitely making use of his assists
that he has available at a time so we'll
see how armsie fares against him the
only surprising thing to me is no Yamcha
at the end instead I'm like Super Saiyan
Goku or something that's like more
standard you know just so strong yeah
Super Saiyan Goku just offers a lot of
utility and I think a lot of people like
playing it for that reason
okay right off the bat with Ichiko
voices great tech they're from rmz
because both assists are gone and he
problem all the way to the corner dragon
rushes the most air back dashing look at
that spacing under the GZ go glistens B
plug on so good at that in the last like
I feel like month or two they've really
really kind of like gotten used to
dealing with the assist yeah Champa Bell
counter on that brings in Bartok get
some over the dome
yeah incoming set up is really really
rough the block makes team go on a great
addition to any team that wants to be
oppressive in the corner back to ash get
split sparks up he's kind of in a weird
spot there so I don't think that that's
a bad idea
hold man is punished I'm gonna put a lot
of meet her
I like if it drops out of the combo
there yeah that is a bad drop example
off yeah man just pick up the pressure
again though so arms II still in a
decent place but super - house gosh
power getting out of that
cancel that was a little high to combo
yeah but it was gonna tempt us now
without jumping at all yeah young trust
that's coming up here soon but the
Lariat it's gonna land that hit yeah
it's great what you think Oh Chris s
just covers so much ground yeah so much
blue screen is just cut off horizontally
and I level 1 level 3 a lot of damage
and against the sparking you're not the
sparking on a block stun gonna take the
snap bring in Co the drop
that's unfortunate especially after
getting that hit off the empty loves to
H no I think it was looking for it but
just not quite fast enough
yeah sometimes that happens sometimes
you try it and it's just not quick
enough this time doesn't start up like
the tag yeah get some out of there the
corner it's are they smart idea people
miss their setups where they back off a
little bit okay
going into the jump ins right into the
dragon rush
popliteus is flash go sliding knockdown
going into the level 3 with dad gonna
spit at all yeah oh yeah
all the meter 7 bars worth it gets the
kill one arm maybe all you need some pot
you can harness that much power all
taking the front I love love love to
mash that that were the big delay there
and I'm with the good challenge yeah I
like RMP challenging that dragon rush
goes powerful down
great defense here Fattah chicawa the
i'll fog annealed i'm not long enough
there we go debrief bars built from arm
see here going into the bar talk level 3
that would look great chase after the
risk on the hot to get the air to air
into the full combo after do like a lazy
vanish or anything actually got the full
confirm that was really really good
I love the pacing of this game so far
it's kind of even for the most part both
players keep going back and forth
praying
[Music]
so you stood up and they got smoked for
it stanchion that's surprised no one
would 1 level 3 is a lot of damage
anyway live in little little magic pixel
lab all the reverse cancel he try to
reflect to I think actually me with that
keep my Oh run up tag and gets flipped
by it kind of block cross up I think I
like the changes and you're gonna
hopefully get some of that blue health
back your Itachi collar right now oh
that's a punish I spoke too soon yeah
this is gonna be a dead GT after that do
you change level one no he chose the
javelin gonna keep fire doc in house
beautiful he has RAM 9 pig feet the two
owl I like that too because armed is
seen then he ran up and try to challenge
upon oh he dropped some what happened I
don't think he believed he had the head
and didn't believe and he he's like on
his lap right now he's mashing the light
he's I was mashing that think you're
gonna get away with that option though
gave the candy tech to this man he
handed in the cans the sugar level is
brighter levels man he's over 9000
rolling cross dragon a rush nice break
yeah the 6m backs off after it I like
back we found a perfect attack at that
hey Koppel characters that might have
been lights out reflect on ish I like it
very good if you have that long-range ki
blast like he does very good for those
kind of situations
it really is it's scary it's a scary
situation to be in this is one of those
characters extend it and snap out again
you're playing upset mode again sparking
out of it I don't blame him especially
with cell being the one that was just
dragged back in hold managed to escape
the corner good choice in the air back
that's after unfortunate like that's
parking without obviously so you can
hold vanish the problem or anything but
an important hit and that's that calm
board within drop pawn is great punish
on that guard cancel there some loops
here in the corner oh wow today there's
more than drop that I must gonna act
drop there to no punish but back to the
corner pervert attack out now this
should be look I'm sorry I think it's
just the little body bar is just a
little character I said it was gonna be
the kill I don't know why box there -
this time
so itself to be fair to is one of those
bigger characters too so it's like an
even bigger pair for the normal with the
really tiny yeah I'm surprised I felt
like that baby was gonna hit it was
gonna be no problems we've seen so many
drops so far especially the like the
last you said it because it feels like
what is happening alright everybody
combos never heard of them and it's not
like it's one person or something to
your eye it's like everybody on stage
has been having trouble so far on that
drag rush they're super - through but
vicious to finish out there
good time to guard cancel bring in the
GT Goku with the full health you got
both of them for a second there yeah
together sandwiches a lot of times in
this game because he didn't have that
much life Wow
he's heavy version of that that is good
move here for touch power auto combo out
of the corner and they call Bardock and
then still have pressure line force is
sparking here in the front nice block
get away okay I like that I like
changing out and just team go on no no
pun and then you had to go up in the air
to get a punish there and it would have
avoided the Yamcha as well which is
important I like how he protected
himself being in the air with the on
ptosis so great yeah if your arm Z right
there you get stuck under that you have
to jump up an air there which is like
the scary part and the second you don't
that y'all just this is gonna flip you
runs up air - and the hell
looking like a seen game here for
thought Chicago sitting on sparking
draggin her up office right back up with
that dragon fresh he was moving that was
that was really fast wasn't able to
build okay now here the hit sparking
mark to get the kill
yeah there's no drop here this is gonna
be eight dead GT Goku right with that
level one yeah he's a music talk I hit
him with a Nam alright alright okay the
candy powers are working now for
Tachikawa wiping off the hands maybe he
got them gamer goo began that is the
grossest thing I've ever heard
that is a bad time for anything why
would you I guess like to me MIT but
like watch your name you know I'm not
gonna question it but yeah but all the
guys have been posting pictures they're
like things thanks my hands were not
sweaty thanks to this gamer goo Yogi's
know this pal
I don't know what's going on out there
in the world catch me anywhere else in
the world but would you need to get rid
of it like you be gone I wouldn't cuz
imagine if I had that on my head I
couldn't touch my Wow
the auto car my hair I couldn't like I
couldn't shake
barks Eric get out come out the banished
to vanish oh my drop what is happening
so far holds vanish sell vs. GT right
now it's just very unfortunate we just
had so many drops in general and it's
not be like but most consistently we've
seen them right now with these two
characters yeah finally a super - all
right Dragan Russians pharmacists
available not gonna use it probably just
for pressure and there's the spark tank
beats the tag back in so knowing that
this has been a difficult character to
deal with here betrayed yeah
it's rolling cross straight down that's
a good try out of fear
yeah I catch eyes bowls markings off the
table already and salads getting beat up
you know he didn't do tagged out or a
character like gg-go good so you can get
a lunch of life back for some reason it
look like really strong you know I don't
blame you
he was just falling from the sky onto
system blocks on no idea whether he's
gonna go overhead low air - what it was
gonna be - Goku not not exactly the best
place to be in GT Goku a very strong
character but by himself you know for
how strong of a character he is not that
shot by himself from Moscow yes the
Autobahn boy I said light light light
and R&Z reacted but it was too late oh
man the same thing we just saw in that
last set up in the corner three bars
trying just hold on for dear life here
seven bars on deck - if he can even make
work of it right now
you know the UK doesn't want to see
their their hero go home just yet it's
like an Iron Man there's a long long
road all you have to do is hit touch
Kawa 11 times have you can hit him this
is really scary spot to be in and
there's the hit that's gonna kill
tachikoma moving on who's our side there
- give it up for them everybody knows
good loser back losses match we had a
couple of good losers bracket matches
that we just saw they're back to back
right cool to watch and obviously
thought Chicago and I'm moving on he's
gonna be playing up against the apology
man in our losers side we're gonna have
that sub
knock he'll match right before that so a
lot of good Dragon Ball coming up and
obviously that winners finals West Coast
action it's gonna be super noon and
Christopher chief so that should be a
fun match tune into as well so hopefully
you guys are enjoying it all so far with
this is the last tank ihe event on a
Dragonball Fighters world tour before we
get into our saga events in the finals
we're going to take a short break when
we come back we'll have the rest of this
bracket here so stay tuned everybody in
Kachin in just a little bit